hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the hidden effect with
epigenetic discovery and Judy O'Rourke
of labyrinth and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring in this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
Rockland on McCall is dr. Karen abarca
heidemann Ross Lynch director of
research and development hello everybody
hello everybody rapid advances in the
field of epigenetics are revealing a
molecular basis of how heritable
information other than DNA sequence can
influence gene function at the genetic
findings add to our understanding of
transcriptional regulation nuclear
organization development and cc's
rockland is a manufacturer of research
tools and the strength importance of the
scientific advances and is proud to
support and work together with
scientists like dr. Kim dr. Borrero and
dr. Sharia that will be presenting today
rock and support academic biopharma and
agnostic industries with antibodies and
undergoing space tools for over 50 years
thank you Karen we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the dream Q&A button
lower left this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the c/e button
at the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits I would
now like to introduce today's speakers
dr. Jeffrey Kim dr. carlos ferrero and
dr. christopher sharer dr. Kim has
worked in oral health research the last
10 years and has a broad perspective of
the field he received specific training
institute stem cell biology regenerative
medicine neuronal specific
differentiation bioinformatics
next-generation sequencing technologies
salivary gland biology developmental
biology chemical toxicology drug abuse
and addiction dr. Kim has extensive
experience in analyzing embryonic cells
and tissues in the context of
identifying the regenerative potential
and profiling the genome and epigenome
based on previous collaborative projects
it has developed great working
relationships and strong communication
skills with his collaborators and has
established strong ties with experts
from oral biology and bioinformatics in
government and academic research
institutions if current projects address
repair and regenerative mechanisms in
the context of oral health dr. Carlos a
barreiro is a research assistant
professor at the School of Pharmacy at
Temple University his research interests
focus on applying proteomics
metabolomics and bioinformatics
technologies for the study of
pathological mechanisms of different
diseases dr. Borrero has made
substantial impact to the knowledge of
pathological mechanisms underlying COPD
his current interest is to explore the
ability of H 3.3 to be used as an early
marker and as if there are putative
target for COPD progression which will
have a direct translational application
and will assist greatly in the
identification and treatment of patients
with this disease dr. Borrero has made
similar contributions in the areas
obesity and in hiv/aids Christopher's
share received his BSC and PhD from
Emory University in Atlanta Georgia
during his graduate work to study the
role of oncogenic transcription factors
under the mentorship of dr. carlos
moreno in 2009 he joined dr. jeremy boss
laboratory as a postdoctoral fellow
later progressing to instructor in 2014
and more recently assistant professor
dr. boss's lab his research focused on
identifying epigenetic mechanisms of T
and B cell differentiation currently dr.
shares research focuses on improving and
adapting sequencing applications flow
cell input numbers including attack seek
gypsy methyl seek and RNA seek he
currently leads an effort to integrate
these epigenome mapping technologies to
understand normal Indian function and
autoimmune diseases through identifying
pathogenic at the genetic signatures
using a systems biology approach he aims
to reverse-engineer the environment
environmental stimuli that impact human
disease and discover novel biomarkers
and therapeutic targets I will now turn
it over to dr. Borrero for his
presentation
hello everybody and thank you Judy for
your presentation I also want to thank
Rockland for the invitation to present
my work in this webinar today I'm going
to show you an unconventional function
of the histones that have been recently
studied in the last past few years but
first let me show you a brief
introduction of what histones normally
do there as many of you know as maybe
all of you know histones they are
several class of histones there are five
families h2a h2b h3 and all of an H for
all of them build up a new clothes on
that is the basic structure of the
chromatin to wrap around and condensate
the DNA in the nucleus this these
systems have a amine and c-terminal
tails that are highly modified in
different amino acid residues and the
modifications include the set elation
methylation phosphorylation citroen
elation adp-ribosylation simulation and
ubiquitination the main function of this
system is to keep the DNA wrap around
and as seen here in in the in the
presentations and allow the gene
expression when they are required then
by modifying the histones tails the
there are several enzymes that are key
regulators of this process in in in a
context of epigenetics but this is when
the histones are present normally in
inside of the nuclear inside of the
cells what happened when the systems are
a present extracellularly outside of the
cells let me tell you the histones can
be cytotoxic for the cells and they can
produce injury in different tissues all
around the body they can induce
inflammation through a specific
receptors including toll-like receptors
and these extra cellular systems are
mainly release by immune cells that are
activated like and neutrophils and
macrophages in a process in different
process of activation for neutral field
is called mitosis or they can also be
released by cell dead during apoptosis
or necrosis these cells the histo
cellular systems also induce itself
apoptosis as we described in our work
through in a receptor that is still
unknown so far including the different
including the lungs and also there are
several tissues that get affected by
histones as in the brain by stroke and
liver injury and the kidney injury the
histones can induce also pancreatitis
retinitis and also has been described to
be implicated in the cretan rd
attachment for the purpose of our
conference we are going to go deep in
the study of hokey stones or accessory
histones are related to the pathogenesis
of COPD a little bit about COPD series a
disease that is characterized is an
inflammatory chronic disease that has
destruction intensive destruction of the
lung tissue mainly in response to smoke
and what has been known for their case
is that the a cigarette smoke induced
increase in the intracellular reactive
oxygen species and these reactive oxygen
species modifies the histone deacetylase
enzymes allowing the existence to keep
acetylated and inducing as the
transcription of the inflammatory genes
our reasons work add to this knowledge
additional arm of these
condition in which the inhibition of the
edge duck contribute to the accumulation
of the high porosity lated histone 3
that is resistant to be degraded and
when the cells died they get released to
extracellular space inducing cells with
toxicity and beam deleterious for this
rounded cells promoting the COPD
progression let me show you how we did
these needles in detail initially we
perform proteomic study using label free
analysis in which we compare the COPD
lung tissue against the control tissue
that we come from normal and patients
and when we perform this proteomic
analysis the protein that highlight with
most the significant difference was
histone 3.3 with a fall difference then
we decide to characterize these proteins
and study deeply first we did a
confirmation of of the histone tree in
the tissues that were subject to the
proteomics analysis and we did a
validation study in a large number of
samples of different degrees of COPD and
very severe gold and known as gold for
or moderate COPD cause as 93 and they
were very significantly increased levels
when they are compared with the control
group then we decided to look where the
histones were located inside of the
tissue and for our surprise we were able
to find the histones that were
extracellularly in the airspace and more
importantly they were interacting with
the epithelial broke epithelial cells we
also were able to identify these free
histones in the bronchoalveolar lavage
and in the plasma i'm giving an
indication that these histones can be a
martyr for COPD then we decided to
evaluate what was the origin of the
other expression of the histones
initially we test day
transcription of the different genes of
histone 3.3 man wien so significant
difference but when we evaluate the
degradation of the histone 3.3 we were
able to find isoform of the histones
that I ubiquitinated and applying the
proteomics technology we identify the
specific residues where the histones
were were modified by a rickety nation
then we also applying the same
technology were able to map the whole
most occasions in the protein in the
histone tree and we found that the
histone tree is hyper acetylated in the
end term of the histone tree and this
finding was confirmed by load blood in
independent subjects of COPD and all
this object with COPD have high porosity
related systems compared to the subject
they control subjects in in the control
groups more importantly we are able now
to differentiate patients that have COPD
by measuring the histone tree and the
its modifications they acetylation of
the histone tree but the importance of
this is country to be extracellular Lee
in the lung tissue was then assessed by
a different experiments and lead to
demonstrate that the histones were
apoptotic to primarily from capital
cells and we were able to initially we
measure the incorporation of an X in
five and we saw that the histone 3
extracted from the lungs of the patients
were cytotoxic even the normal distance
that is not modify it doesn't have any
acetylation so modifications however
it's still very cytotoxic this system
the ace 3.3 is more cytotoxic that the
rest of the histones and this
cytotoxicity is dose-dependent okay they
the one of the clear experiments that we
need to illustrate that they are
cytotoxic we ever expressed the histones
in intracellular weight or in up and a
form that is clear
when we saw the histone that is
recruited into the media we saw that the
toxicity was about seventy percent only
thirty percent of the cells survive and
more importantly this cytotoxicity can
be prevented by the specific antibodies
that recognize the N or the C term of
the system then this and later we
confirmed by western blot that they
apoptosis induced by by histones in
these primary cells through activation
of gas phase and the we perform our
proteomic analysis on these cells and to
summarize the finding of the mechanistic
that are implicated in the in the cell
toxicity due to age 33 we found a
activation of the calcium signaling
pathway and we found activation of the
unfolded protein respond pathway that is
a stress response that the cells produce
and we also found mitochondrial
cytotoxicity we perform several blocks
studies and we were able to see that
immediately after we put the histones in
these primary cells there is a flocks of
calcium that activate the release of
calcium from the end plasmic reticulum
they get incorporated into into the
mitochondria and this event happen
several times after the histones are in
contact with a with the cells really a
finally doing damage on the membrane
potential of the mitochondria and
releasing different castes or activating
apoptotic also through an independent
way downstream off of UPR finally when
these cells are dead they release more
of the acetylated histones that were
accumulated at the resistance and they
perpetuate the cycle of debt then the
implications or the application of our
work have now linked the histone 3 as a
possible cause
of inflammatory of the inflammatory
response that characterize COPD we are
now doing another experiments using
proteomics technology to quantify his
country in plasma and uses his country
on its modification as a biomarker for
COPD and we are also developing some
assets trying to look for molecules that
can be used as a pharmacological
approach to prevent the histone tree
toxicity but let me finish my
presentation showing an unpublished
results that we have done to demonstrate
day in BO toxicity of his country and
the toxicity of the histone tree
acetylated basically we instill the
recombinant histone 3 or they
assassinated isoform of the histone tree
into the lung of the mice and 48 hours
later we evaluate the lung tissue damage
by different techniques our results
initially we just confirmed that the
histones are present extracellularly in
the parenchyma of of the lungs as well
as interacting with the ROM capital
cells use one hour later after we do the
installation and 48 hours later we see
dramatic change in the epithelium of the
controls compared to the histone 3 you
can see enlargement of the of the bronco
bacterial cells as well as infiltration
cellular infiltration in the parenchyma
of the cells with destruction of the
halls of the elder life this is these
results are more severe in when he when
acetylated histones was used it was
instigated into the mice and these
results were also confirmed that they
are inducing apoptosis as shown in this
immunized oh chemistry like as pastry
and caspase-9 activated and the cells
that are dying are basically the cells
that make the bridge in in a normal
alveoli function
then we confirm our results and the
anatomical findings in using micro CT
and where you can see in this
reconstruction of the lungs of demise
the more severe damage of the lung is
caused by acid acetylated histones or
hyper acetylated histones that we use
and more importantly we were able to
characterize the the inflammatory
response in where we saw that different
cytokines like interleukin-6 tnf-alpha
p.m. cp3 are highly expressed as in an
acute form after day in a long
inoculation of the histones for example
was happening into the COPD patients
okay now to conclude I want to summarize
what I have presented today and they are
different source of histones that can be
from immune cells activated or from
dying cells through apoptosis or
necrosis they are initially needed to
kill bacteria but they also can can can
be damaged for normal tissue and the
consequence they can induce a lot of
injury and inflammation in this specific
tissue they can also be induced
activation of playlists and induced rom
bosses they can also play disposed to
autoimmune disease by the release of the
DNA that is attached to the new person
but they but the good news is that there
are several molecules that are known
already that are able to degrade or to
block the histone toxicity and we are
looking for more okay thank you so much
for for your attention I want to
acknowledge all collaborators here at
Temple University at temple hospital and
this will have been supported by an
Irishman and psy attended Medical
Research Institute thank you thank you
dr. Barrera for that informative
presentation I will now turn it over to
dr. Kim good
ternoon everyone my name is Geoffrey
camp I'm a project leader for ad a
foundation in Gaithersburg Maryland I
would also like to thank Rockland for
giving me this opportunity to speak to
you today these are my learning
objectives for today how could help
engineering analysis enhance your
research what high-throughput epigenetic
analysis are currently available and
tips on how on sample preparation and
choosing a core facility and what to do
with your raw data after they come back
from the core facility and also
correlating epigenetic data to gene
expression and downstream application as
well and i'll be using our recent
publication to give specific examples on
how these learning objectives can be
applied to your own research so the
areas of research that may benefit from
epigenetic analysis or cancer aging
developmental biology stem cell biology
toxicology pharmacology and
environmental toxicology brain function
and mental disorders and many many many
more the currently available
high-throughput epigenetic analysis
include DNA methylation including M deep
sequencing restriction based methods
bisulfite sequencing as well as histone
modification analysis including chip
sequencing using histone marks RNA
associating silencing analysis
non-coding RNAs people associated short
RNAs and micrornas I like to point out
that DNA methylation and histone
modifications the ability of Pacific and
I but a tech chip great is very crucial
for success of this analysis
so tips on sample preparation genomic
DNA for EM deep sequencing or chip
sequencing you have to have a clean DNA
prep without RNA DNA protein
contamination to begin with and you like
to check that to a QC control before
sending out to the lab fragmentation
step is also important and you want to
do it so that there's no heat damage ah
nice and short sequence range of G&H
size should be checked before sending
out to the lab as well the IP step has
to be performed with the chip grade
antibody and the quality control with
chip qpcr before investing costly
sequencing will be advised and again IP
step may require some optimization in
terms of buffer choices incubation time
and number of washing steps and so on
tips on choosing a cold facility
obviously a local coal facilities
preferred they may help you in some
preparation and doing running some QP
analysis as well as post sequencing data
processing experience co facility with
publication record is highly recommended
and sometimes it's difficult to find a
core facility near you in that case it's
also possible to look for a good one
from a high impact publication they're
usually mentioned in the knowledge meant
section so what to do with your raw data
once it comes back from the co facility
so you want to establish a post
sequencing plan with a bioinformatic
expert before sending out your sample
and I think that's one of the common
mistakes that people are
sending out the sample not knowing that
how to analyze the raw data and once you
they receive it and second thing is
right data usually they're in a fast q
type of file and they're not aligned to
the reference genome yet so you need to
use short read liner such as full time
to align your raw data to the genome and
once the file is aligned to a genome
usually they're in same type of format
and they're ready to be used for further
analysis so what to do with the raw data
part um first thing is you want to
perform quality control experiments
again using a line file and you want to
subtract the background noise using igg
control and you want to identify in rich
region it's also known as a calling and
there are numerous applications and
programs that you could use and you
annotate the in rich region to the
nearest genes so from this point on I'm
going to use specific examples to
further understand our learning
objectives for today so before
concerning concerning costly sequencing
analysis the alleged types of type of
essays they're very inexpensive and easy
to do and you can get a lot of good
information from that before doing the
sequencing losses so for example here we
did alcohol treatment on human embryonic
stem cells in a different concentration
and then we looked at 5-methylcytosine a
percentage using ledger and then we
realized that alcohol does change DNA
methylation the global DNA methylation
so at this point we were ready to do
further analysis and targeted approaches
so it's very important to color eight
your methylation data to gene expression
so what you're looking at here is the
y-axis represents full change using
microarray and the x-axis represents DNA
methylation values and the green dots
represents the genes genes there that we
were interested in so therefore change
with alcohol treatment increased and
their methylation value decreased and
the yellow dots represents decrease in
gene expression with alcohol treatment
and increase in methylation and another
way to represent the same data is the
left blue box represents gene expression
and methylation change upon
differentiation of stem cells just no
more differentiation and the right green
box represents gene expression and
methylation change upon alcohol
treatment and in the middle is subset of
genes that we were interested in that
I'll call induce differentiation related
to alcohol alcohol induce
differentiation related genes and next
performing a functional validation is
very important so the blue bars
represent control cell expression and
the red bar represents alkyl decreasing
direct gene expression and the green bar
represents 5 paisa cytosine treatment
gel expression and as you may know that
5 laser treatment innovates DNA
methylation so here by controlling the
DNA methylation we were able to revert
gene expression change due to alcohol so
heading of a functional validation is
very important there are many different
types of downstream applications and one
example is finding relevant
transcription factors and common motifs
and we use stem program to further
understand our cause effect of course
epigenetic effect on stem cell
differentiation here so hopefully my
presentation achieve our learning
objectives today how we could use
epigenetic analysis to enhance your
research as well as some of the
high-throughput epidemiologist are
available today and tips on sample
preparation as well as choosing a co
facility and when the raw data comes
back from the core facility what to do
with them as well as correlating
epigenetic data to chin expression and
some of the downstream effect downstream
applications so thank you for your
attention that's my email and if you
have any questions feel free to email me
and our project was funded by nih opal a
and firm from California and nidcr
training grants thank you very much
thank you dr. Kim for that great
presentation next we'll hear from dr.
sharer I will now turn it over to him
thank you hi my name is Christopher
share and I'm at Emory University and
today I'd like to thank rockland for
giving me the opportunity to present my
research and i'll talk to you about the
role of epigenetics and regulating the
timing of gene expression during peace
optimization and some of our work using
some emerging applications are mapping
technologies for epigenetics for our lab
works on the ability of your body to
make anybody's so details which are
class and cell type with anybody balance
to the surface are able to differentiate
into plasma cells the porn recognition
of antigens plasma cells are long-lived
cells that are dedicated to any body
secretion and can secrete up to ten to
the seven antibodies per second
anybody's can last for up to the
lifetime of the host and are good in
that they can protect you from infection
from it Linda polio but are bad in
circumstances were so production of
antibodies to self-antigens such as in
autoimmune diseases is pathogenic and
problematic and so understanding how
this process of differentiation from B
cells to plasma cells is regulated is
important so we're interested and what
the epigenetic processes are that
regulate this differentiation process
and the cells go from acquiring cell
type to itself live dedicated to making
anybody's and in with the goal of canvas
process being manipulated for both good
in terms of what we want to induce these
plasma cells and in times when
autoimmune diseases can we develop
targets to inhibit pathogenic plasma
cells so we developed a model of B cell
differentiation in the mouse invito we
did this by taking B cells purifying
them from a mouse labeling them with a
division dye called cfset that allows us
to track which cell division they are in
and also these B cells contain a
congenic marker called cd45 one that
allows us to track the adoptively
transferred b cells we put these cells
into a mouse and um team else which does
not have B cells allowed them to home
for one day and then we inoculate these
mice with the bacterial cell wall
component LPS and look at the phenotype
in the response three days later on the
bottom you can see flow cytometry plots
of congenitally marks be so so the cd45
were marker on the x-axis sirs that we
can find the B cells that we transferred
on the right plot you should see what
happens in a mouse that was not injected
without the
s in that all the B cells are positive
for the b220 marker on the y-axis which
is a be so marker however when we
differentiate and look three days later
after LPS injection we see the formation
of plasma cells as shown by acquisition
of the CD 138 cell surface marker and
that the platform blasts in the red box
are cycling cells whereas the plasma
cells in the orange box are post mitotic
cells now when we look at division using
the cffc die in these cells one of the
things we notice is that these cells
undergo venir out the subdivision before
they acquire differentiation markers so
we can pick out the cell the division
states of each cell such that the
farthest to the right is cell that have
to die and that every division that dies
diluted to fold and so we can physically
track self that have gone through 1246
or cells here which has gone through
eight or nine divisions before they
acquire the city 138 marker final cells
and this was intriguing to us as we had
did not know in vivo that B cells went
through this many divisions and that
there was a lot more division required
before differentiation in order to
understand what was going on at the
molecular level of these cells we fax
sorted out specific divisions we sorted
division 0135 and sell that have gone
through 9 and more divisions and
acquired the CD 138 marker we were able
to isolate 20,000 cells at each division
and our first step was to analyze these
cells by qpcr to look at what the gene
expression profile was of known markers
of plasma cells and B cells this is a
heat map showing the percent 18s of
biological triple kit for division 1 0 1
3 5 or 9 with red indicating higher
expression and green indicating lower
expression one of the things we noticed
was that there is a
group of genes that there are distinct
patterns to these gene expression
changes such that there are genes here
which are induced as the self
differentiate the plasma cells genes
that are repressed as these cells
differentiate and jeans that are turned
on at the activation stage but are
eventually repressed and these could be
divided out into six basic patterns of
gene expression such that you have
progressive changes here or genes such
as ezh2 are continuously up regulated by
they self differentiate and you also
have genes too cute such as cd28 which
is a self-service marker that only comes
on at the end and the differentiated
state the same can be true of both the
repressed genes where you have
progressively progressed progressively
repressed genes and genes that are
repressed specifically at the end of the
differentiated sulphide and we were
curious in understanding what the
molecular epigenetic mechanisms were
that were controlling these different
patterns of gene expression during the
divisions and differentiation so
epigenetic mechanisms that control gene
expression primarily consist of histone
modifications and DNA methylation with
different unique combinations of histone
modifications such as histone h3 k27
acetylation h3k4 modern methylation
president enhancers with h3k27
acetylation and k4 trimethylation
present and active promoters these
methylation marks are lost in the
repressed state and replaced by
methylation marks like k-27 tri methyl
and the assimilation marks are also lost
so unique combinations of histone
modifications can tell you what the
potential is at the locus and whether a
Djinni is primarily on or off another
surrogate for this however is the
accessibility of chromatin to DNA
binding proteins or as genes that are on
and enhancers that are on and typically
accessible for as enhancers that are off
are typically losing accessibility now
this is primarily been measured by the
accessibility of
chromatin to DNA's and done however
recently the development of the attack
sea cafe has changed how we measure
clones and accessibility if we wanted to
measure different combinations of
histones we would perform chip seek
which requires roughly ten to the six to
ten to the seven cells per anybody here
we would need up to four antibodies to
accurately measure the different
chromatin states however that taxi gas a
which reads out chromatin accessibility
can be performed from one to fifty
thousand cells show a high level of
sensitivity and is in the cell range
that we can isolate this method was
developed by the Greenleaf flatten out
of Stanford in 2013 and it works by
using taking advantage of the fact that
it transposon loaded with sequencing
adapters can only integrate its payload
into accessible regions of DNA such that
treatment of cells with the transposon
tags and primes accessible regions of
DNA with sequencing adapters DNA can
then simply be purified pcr-amplified
into a sequence of library in sequence
to map accessible regions this actually
is sensitive and efficient it can be
completed in about half of a working day
provides a readout for the epigenetic
state such that accessibility
traditionally means active for in
accessibility means inactive and you can
identify enhancers promoters the DNA
binding protein footprints and new
please don't positioning since these
both protect the transposon from
integrating its payload we profiled the
same divisions we did by RNA with the
attack sea cafe here you're looking at
the change in accessibility at 31,000
accessible regions between divisions 0
through 9 with red indicating high
levels of accessibility and greed
indicating low levels of accessibility
we found that there are regions here
that were accessible in the division 0
that lost accessibility as they turn
b-cell to move to class results and
regions here that were not accessible
at Division zero but gained
accessibility as he cells differentiated
we identified about thousand accessible
sites that were specific to division
zero one three or five but around six
thousand flights that were you CLE
accessible to division nine the
principal component analysis looking at
how these the variation between the
different accessible sites and the
subtypes showed that in PCA one division
nine was the most unique from division
013 or five but there were unique
differences between division 0 1 3 and 5
and this was surprising to us and we did
not previously understand how the
chromatin accessibility landscape was
remodeled very early and progressively
but that the largest amount of variation
occurred upon differentiation since the
chip seek is not in the range of the
cell types we isolated we were able to
use on code data and other publicly
available data to annotate are
accessible regions and provide
functional such that unique combinations
of histones such as the presence of h3k4
trimethylation with 83 k 27 assimilation
denotes expressed transcription start
sites we have toys enhancers which are
marked by only the presence of HIV cape
on 10 methylation we have a host of
sites that had no known modifications
and represent novel accessible sites the
plasma cells is active enhancers which
are marked by hdk for mono methylation
in h3k27 acetylation and interestingly
these bivalent regions which had both
the repressive and active histone marks
and it was these regions that we wanted
to follow up with so bivalent chromatin
domains are typically found at regions
that have both the dual presence of
active and repressive modifications all
the same nucleosomes and these are
typically that are active a to the K for
mono or trimethylation in the same the
clue zone as the h3k27 trimethylation
marks these allow for rapid induction of
gene expression and often regular
developmentally important genes the
repressive modification in h3k27
trimethylation has deposited by the
enzyme ezh2 in the recent five to ten
years the disc zone and epigenetic
modifying enzymes has seen a lot of
target as drug targets for drug degrees
so that there are about 50 to 60 drugs
that are currently in different phases
of testing and clinical trials most of
them are targeted to the histone
deacetylase inhibitors but there are
those that target the histone
methyltransferases glaxosmithkline has
developed one GSK 343 that specifically
targets ezh2 and we're able to use this
and get a hands-on this to look at what
the effects are of h3k27 trimethylation
in our system we simply wanted to ask
the question we inhibit ezh2 using GSK
343 what is the effect on the cell
differentiation and does this have an
impact on the timing of gene expression
we were able to take advantage of an ex
vivo cell culture system here where we
take these cells out of a mouth and
culture them in the presence of LPS and
I'll 295 cytokines for three days and we
know from previous history in our lab
that we get a very robust
differentiation and so we added the GSK
343 into the system to test what happens
in the presence and absence of this
Victor we are able to show that with
increasing amounts of gsk3 43 we
specifically inhibit the by Western the
h3k27 trimethylation on and hit it and
other methylation marks such as h3k4
trimethylation or total history levels
when we assay the effect of this drug on
differentiation by flow cytometry we get
it on nine percent of ourselves
different shape the plasma cells after
three days however in the presence of
gsk-3 43 we see about a tune asphalt
increase in a number of plasma cells
formed after three days this is
quantitated here on the right we
performed RNA seek on themselves to
analyze what the gene expression changes
were in the presence of gsk-3 43 if we
look at the annotation of genes
upregulated we see that the protein
secretion and the unfolded protein
response are some of the processes that
have been up regulated and this is known
to occur in plasma cells as they secrete
such high levels of antibody it causes
stress on themselves and they
upregulated the unfolded protein
response in order to deal with that
stress we also find that they down
regulate and change their metabolism and
this is all so unexpected and that we do
not know how they self metabolically
change from a quiescent to an active
cell type we also find that key plasma
cell transcription factors are
upregulated while the key b-cell
transcription factors are downregulated
and chief among these factors was the
blimp one which is a master
transcriptional regulator of plasma cell
faith the blimp one was also interesting
to us and that if we look at the blimp
one locus and here you're showing the
two annotated promoters 4.1 and each of
these tracks shows the signal for a taxi
cat divisions 0 through 9 here you can
see a peak of accessibility time flows
were born promoters and both promoters
are accessible at division 0 at a time
when the blimp one is not expressed
however born is expressive division nine
and so we want want to understand what
was regulating the timing of expression
despite the promoter being accessible at
earlier divisions so we turn into our ex
vivo system and it returned to a mouse
that contain the blimp 1 Y Fe reporter
develops by suit xlab these mice have
the blimp one promoter with a yfb
transgene introduced so that there is a
fluorescent readout for expression that
mirrors that in vivo blimp one
expression we labeled these cells with
the divisions dies CTV so that we can
also track the
the emergence of life the expression in
relation to some provision and then
treated them in the presence or absence
of gsk-3 43 with our differentiation
cocktail we found that division on the Y
on the x axis here versus blimp 1 YP
expression on the y axis we said these
cells go through cell division but that
in the presence of gsk3 43 we have about
a two and a half fold increase in the
amount of glenthorn yfp positive cells
and that if we look at the blimp one yfp
expression by division that the GSK 343
treated cells expressed blimp 1 and
earlier division than the control cells
suggesting that ezh2 and htk 27
trimethylation regulate plan for clients
expressed developmentally so our model
here is that normally during retail
differentiation after activation they
smell proliferate for a period while
they undergo chromatin remodeling prior
to your terminal differentiation in that
ezh2 represses blimp 1 such that the
cell can pull if rate and for terminally
differentiating in the presence of the
inhibitor ezh2 is repressed in these
cells divide more but also terminally
different shade more such that B cell
differentiation is coupled to the
rearrangement of accessible chromatin
and ezh2 seems to regulate the magnitude
and timing a plasma cell differentiation
and this may allow for processes such as
selection and regulation of the
magnitude of an antibody response to be
regulated in vivo and this is also
interesting to us because epigenetic
therapeutic agents can be
immunomodulatory and that treating
patients with these inhibitors is going
to have effects on the immune system
with that I like to thank the members of
our lab to contribute to this work and
our collaborators Apple of Kappa
biosystems and rocky standard labs the
different course facilities and our lab
has positions available and I thought I
thank you very much
listening thank you for those
informative presentations before we get
started on the question-and-answer
session i would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button the lower left
of the presentation window will try to
answer as many questions as we can then
our first question is are all histones
cytopathic and equally and this would be
for Carlos hello I showing my results
the kiss on three at least for the
Bronco battalion cells are more
cytotoxic that the other histones but
there is evidence that histone for is
also highly cytotoxic and followed by
histone to be and when the histor cell
complex as a nucleosome they still are
cytotoxic even if they are wrap it
around with DNA they still cytotoxic
annually I'm sure this is an excellent
for you too what were you done with our
yes yes I'm done without you can go to
the next function next one is for you to
in addition to H 3.3 are other histones
toxic and increase in plasma or
extracellular compartment in patient in
the case of the COPD we also look for
some other histones and we were able to
see it but the major difference was in
the histone 3.3 and we we found this one
was hyper acetylated which is also
resistant to be degraded but in other
disease the whole nucleosome complex
which included the four histones are
also present in the in the bloodstream
and they are cytotoxic as a complex too
how did the DNA jizz inhibit the H 3.3
the example of of DNA is a inhibitor is
specific for for the autoimmune disease
because when the cells release DNA they
when the cells die they release new
croissants
wrap it around with DNA than the
nucleosomes protect the DNA to be
decorated then by treating with dnase
you can avoid this disconnection which
is the combination of histone with DNA
is like the source of antigens for auto
antibodies then preventing the DNA to be
there by treating with dnase you reduce
the you will be reducing the possibility
of expose new antigens but the DNA's
will not prevent the toxicity of the
histones how Anna histones finished out
of the DNA or nucleus into the shell
they are as I showed that at least three
different ways in in neutrophils they in
during the process of mitosis when they
release the histones they occur several
enzymatic digestion of the nucleus and
modifications of the systems the systems
becomes I truly needed and then they
eject the whole nucleus outside of the
cells and the cells disappear that's one
thing when when the source of histones
are cells that are dying like during
apoptosis the same thing happened
through cafes or other enzymes that
release fierce they degraded the nucleus
in a small part and vesicles and then
start releasing these small vesicles
outside and during necrosis the whole
cell break apart and release in the
cells the content of histones and a
nucleosome are all the hyper titillated
histones not DNA bound the acetylation
group bound specifically to a life in
which is very basic amino acid residue
and it's a lot of license are in the
tail of the histone tree then normally
these lysing what is not modified is
interacting with DNA because of they of
the charge is positive charge and is
inter
with a negative charge of the DNA but
the modification that is induced by the
acetyl transferase when this acetyl
group is attached to the lysine they
become positive and then they repeal the
introduction of the tale of the histone
from the DNA interaction then you will
assume that that at least that tail is
not any more like hogging the DNA and
holding the DNA and is free of that
interaction at that part but they but
the histone itself the system will still
assemble into the nucleosome and the DNA
can be interacting in different places
but this make more accessible the DNA to
be used for the transcription machinery
to work just be a situation of histones
reduced inflammation they are several
studies analyse this one drug that is
claiming to to enhance the activity of
the histone deacetylase it and they are
a mouse model and impatience they are
using this drug that is increased a
little bit the activity in that way the
acetylation that reduce and they show
that they are improvement in in the
symptomatology of the patients then we
can we can deduce that they will be a
great significance if we are able to
completely abolish the hyper acetylation
of histones in COPD this next might be
needed for Chris how different do this
chip experiment results look depending
on the quality of antibodies yes that's
a very good question they quote with
anybody is probably the largest
determinant of success for a chip
reaction all labs when we're developing
chip assays with new targets whether
it's a histone or transcription factor
we routinely by three to five
commercially they look anybody to test
them all
at the same essay and find very
different results depending on the
different antibodies so finding the
highest quality anybody in your assay is
very important first success and ship
experience Chris I believe this next one
would be for you too is it known if
overexpression of ezh2 changes the total
modification system we don't know
currently if overexpression changes the
modification of histones we know that
ezh2 is proper regulated in our system
but we are theory we believe that it's
more recruitment of ezh2 to specific
sites that changes the modification
versus a global of regulation of the
modification may increase this next
one's for you to my your work on plasma
cells provide potential therapies from
multiple myeloma yes that is a
multiplied loma we also have projects
looking at autoimmune diseases or plasma
cells are component so this is very much
a gullible just to find biomarkers and
potential therapeutic targets for these
diseases change the next one is for you
and it's a three-parter so let me know
if you need me to repeat what is the
advantage of the tax seek over RNA seek
what other information can you get since
you already have five sets of genes and
why don't you go to direct to histone
modification analysis you want to just
take them one at a time sure txt cover
our anything share attack so you can
honestly give you two very different
pieces of information on eccie tells you
the expressed set of genes and what the
level of expression is and so that's an
mrna and an RNA that's a attack seek is
a DNA chromatin assay that tells you
where the regulatory elements are in the
genome and if they're accessible or
active or not so RNA sequence i if your
team is active and the taxi can tear
nicely with that essay to tell you where
the regulation on your genius and so the
other information we can
so since we know we have five or six
classes of genes by methods like RNA
seeking real-time pcr what we don't know
is how those genes are regulated
differently by classes such that the
regulation may be different for genes
that are upregulated progressively
versus a gene that I showed like 11
which needs to be upregulated as a very
specific I mean during differentiation
so we don't go directly the histone
modifications mainly because of some
where limitations and here we're working
with 20,000 cells per a fake and often
times we have to work within a few
thousand and chip seek currently is not
robustly ready for those cell numbers
whereas a taxi can RNA seek are so those
are the assays return to the next one is
I am looking at a gene promoter region
DNA methylation healthy cells usually
have very low methylation there if my
toxicant only decreases the methylation
even further is further decrease in
methylation significantly measurable
using sequencing he wants to take life i
would say certain sequencing
applications for DNA methylation are
dependent on the amount of methylation
present enrichment based assays may not
be the best way here but so bisulfite
sequencing based assays would not be
sensitive to how much methylation you
have it would provide you a digital
readout for the amount of methylation
you have either at a specific locus or
genome-wide okay well we have run out of
time today I would like to once again
thank dr. Kim dr. Borrero dr. Shara for
their presentations do you have any
final comments dr. ken dr. burrow or dr.
sure mmm no comment thank you so much
for the for the time and for you
the gill rotation thank you okay I would
also like to thank our sponsor rockland
for making today's educational webcast
possible this presentation has been
approved for continuing education
credits so if you want to obtain the
credits click on the get your free
secrets button located in the lower left
of your screen this will take you
through a page listing all of our
speakers and presentations please select
the CD button under the presentation and
follow the instructions to claim your
specific it today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
April of 2016 you will receive an email
from lab rest alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to afford then announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event see you next time bye